[Music]
tickets on sale now dude
tickets on sale now dude tickets on sale
now
dude
hello peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get to this
we're gonna get through it together
december 17th hey what's up everyone
jamie and i are here to tell you that
you can start buying tickets for
spider-man no way home starting on
friday monday
no you mean cyber monday
yeah i mean it's also known as cyber
monday i see what you're doing look why
can't it be electro monday
well because i was trying to do like a
phonetics thing i got it check this out
buy your tickets for spider-man no way
home on electro monday
ah it doesn't really get point across
does it nah it doesn't really might not
spider monday it is get your tickets for
spider-man no way home on november 29th
cyber night exactly on spite of monday
and on electro monday sony throws in a
75-inch 4k tv
for us too as well apparently word they
just if they keep scrolling it says and
tom and jamie get two seven it does say
that down does say that but they don't
want to scroll because they don't want
to you know what they want to surprise
us right that's what it is it's a
surprise exactly
just so you know sony's not actually
going to be giving away free tvs but you
should still go get your tickets for
spiderman
[Music]
you